good morning everyone this is Jack and
Horne from the bd2k training
coordinating Center at the University of
Southern California and I'd like to
welcome you all to our big data to
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science today we have the pleasure
of Ali show je from the University of
Washington who's going to be talking on
unsupervised machine learning this
follows on the heels from our talk last
week by Daniella Witten unsupervised
statistical learning but makes a nice
compliment
dr. Cheu je is associate professor of
biostatistics and investment associate
professor of statistics at the
University Washington in Seattle
originally trained in industrial systems
engineering and obtained his PhD in
statistics from the University of
Michigan while completing a master's
degree in Applied Mathematics and Human
Genetics his currently research lies at
the intersection of machine learning for
high dimensional data statistical
network analysis and applications in
biology and the social sciences regular
and short courses on statistical machine
learning and network analysis so we're
very pleased to have Ali here to talk
about his topic of unsupervised machine
learning Ali thank you so much thank you
Jack without introduction and thanks
also to crystal for organizing all these
efforts I also wanted to thank Michelle
dawn who spearheaded many of the efforts
the BTK training activities and was key
in the success of b2k training
activities so so as Jackie mentioned I'm
going to talk about unsupervised machine
learning techniques today and this is
one of the main two classes of
statistical machine learning along with
supervised machine learning which was
the topic of last week's webinar in
supervised machine learning we as some
of you saw last week we use a data set X
to predict or detect Association for the
response Y whereas an unsupervised
machine learning there is no response Y
so we're only looking at a data set X
and we're trying to identify patterns or
signal in that Vincent and that's that's
the topic of today's actually also
mention that there are other categories
of machine learning semi-supervised
learning english is somewhere between
supervised and unsupervised and
reinforcement learning but you will not
talk about those today so to better
understand what unsupervised machine
learning tries to do is helpful to look
at supervised learning which is more
familiar this is a classical supervised
learning task where we have observations
in in the space of features x1 and x2 so
we have two features here this could be
abundance ease of two proteins or
activities of to measure the two
different brain regions and and each dot
in this part correspond to one
subjective let's say and so in addition
to having the measurements of different
subjects for these two features we also
have the labels associated with these
with each subject and and so in this
case we have two labels blue and red and
blue and orange and and so the classical
supervised learning task would be to
classify the observations based on based
on the feature space so an example would
be to define a super support vector
classifier which would be a hyperplane
that would distinguish the blue and an
orange classes and then we could use
this classifier that we've learned let's
say based on some training data in order
to predict the outcome of future
observations the main difference from
supervised learning in the setting of
unsupervised learning is that we still
have the same data we still have the
same features x1 and x2 but we no longer
have the labels for the classes so
instead of having the setting where we
have blue and orange points we just have
let's say grade points we don't know
what these points correspond to all we
know is that we have measurements of x1
and x2 so we can't for example do
classification anymore however we could
still think about ok whether there are
groupings in the data so this would
correspond to a cost training task or
whether there are lower dimensional
represent
that could capture information in the
data or whether there are associations
between the features for example in this
case X 1 and X 2 that would be
meaningful and would help us identify
some patterns in the B so to summarize
the main difference between supervised
learning and unsupervised learning is
that and supervised learning we have a
data matrix X which is an N by P array
of data corresponding to P measurements
for each of and subjects in the previous
example P was 2 we had two measurements
in general we could have more and in
biological applications especially in
biomedical big data we usually have P
and the order of thousands or hundreds
of thousands and Y is a vector of
outcome or response for each for the
subjects and in unsupervised learning we
still have the same data matrix X but we
no longer have a vector of outcome or
response and all we are doing is to look
at the out of the data matrix in order
to identify patterns or signal that is
interesting now why do we use
unsupervised learning given that sort of
there's no CH in association with the
outcome well unsupervised learning is an
important part of the data analysis
pipeline in fact unsupervised learning
is used commonly in the exploited data
analysis case along with the data
wrangling a data visualization a lot of
times our supervised learning techniques
are used to aid data wrangling and data
visualization and sometimes they're used
to generate new hypotheses that that we
could then validate and then data and
this is when we basically identify
interesting patterns in signal in our
data
you know generate hypotheses
unsupervised learning methods are also
used in conjunction with supervised
learning techniques and confirmed
through data analysis so Brian calf will
give a really nice explanation of
exploratory versus confirmatory data
analysis a couple of weeks ago as deep
in one of these webinars and and as he
pointed out oftentimes
analyses are someone in this spectrum of
confirmed exposure ledian analysis to
confirmatory analysis to our analyses
that are purely exploratory
their analyses of hue confirmatory and
their analysis as for someone between
tea and and for many of the analysis
that falls somewhere between the two
unsupervised learning is used
extensively it is important to keep in
mind that when we use data to generate
hypotheses and then later on test those
hypotheses it's been using the same data
there is the findings of our study are
still exploratory we cannot make strong
claims based on what we find
partly because these might not be
reproducible we drive the hypotheses
based on the same data and we have in a
sense evaluated the same hypotheses
using the same data if we want to ensure
the reducibility of results we should
instead use for example a training test
approach that was discussed in last
week's webinar or validation set
approach for example you should use
cross-validation and we should do that
on the whole pipeline so all the steps
from data wrangling data visualization
unsupervised learning which which I
generate some hypotheses all the way to
supervised learning that would verify
these hypotheses or look for association
with the outcome they should be
validated and independent data or in
held-out data set in order to make sure
that there is also reproducible and if
this is not possible then we should
interpret the results as an exploration
of the data should not get potentially
too excited about what we are observing
in our data so with that introduction
we'll focus on two of the main classes
of unsupervised learning methods -
throughout today's webinar we will focus
on clustering techniques and dimension
reduction we will not talk about
Association rule mining and graphical
modeling network analysis which although
interesting you won't have time to cover
them in this lecture clustering of
course is widely used by an analysis of
biomedical big data here's a very well
known example of one of the pioneering
applications of clustering in and outs
of gene expression data war truck crew
and others used
clustering techniques to identify
subtypes of breast cancer and and they
later validated these cost frames and
verified
these subtypes and they use them to
define effective therapies now in
constraining the main objective is
somewhat vague the objective of
clustering is to group meet the objects
into meaningful clusters such that
objects within each cluster are more
similar to one another than objects in
other costumes now the reason that this
is somewhat vague is that depending on
how we define meaningful clusters or
meaningful subsets we could have
different number of clusters and we
could get different cost ratings in our
data it is a simple example what will
depending on how we define what a
meaningful cluster is we might get
different number of clusters one might
reasonably say that okay there are two
clusters in this data set I'm separating
them into red and blue and another
person could also reasonably look at
this data set and say there's six
different clusters and this just the
part depends on how we define clusters
how we define similarity within groups
and and difference outside of these
groups even someone might might look at
this data and say well there are four
clusters all of this is dependent on how
we define meaningful clusters so this is
one of the complications of clustering
similarly the way that we define
similarity among objects has
consequences in terms of what we mean by
meaningful clusters so so here for
example we could consider two clusters
defined on the table based on two curves
in the data or two manifolds in the data
these would be the red and blue clusters
or someone might reasonably use a
different notion of similarity in the
observations and define different
clusters so these are issues that are
important and need to be decided
throughout different clustering tasks
and these different choices would result
in different clustering outcomes in
addition to deciding what we mean by a
meaningful cluster we should also decide
what you want to cluster we have a
couple of different options we could
cluster observations this is the most
commonly used option and for example in
the example in the paper that I showed
you clustering was used in
in order to identify subtypes of breast
cancer the samples were clustered know
to identify subtypes of breast cancer
because I also cluster the features this
this is use extensively we want to
define find genes that have similar
functions for example in order to
identify proxies to biological pathways
in fact costs or both we could cost our
observations and teachers together and
this is often referred to as by
clustering throughout this lecture I'm
given the similarities of these hats we
will focus only on clustering of
observations but but same techniques the
same issues that we will discuss here
will also come up in cost range of
features or in by cluster so today we
will talk about two classes of
clustering techniques hierarchical
methods and partition based methods and
we'll cover an example of each one of
these briefly we will talk about
hierarchical clustering and we'll talk
about k-means clustering hierarchical
clustering is basically a way to get a
sequence of nested clusters that are
organized in a tree structure which is
referred to as a dendrogram and there
are two classes of hierarchical
clustering methods we could build these
trees in a bottom-up fashion starting
with an individual cluster and then
merging them until we get one cluster
that contains all the observations or we
could do it in a top-down way we could
start with one cluster and use it a
measure of distance in order to separate
the clusters further down and get in
separate clusters and these again are
similar somewhat we will focus on
bottom-up approaches here in this
lecture so to explain the main idea of
hierarchical clustering consider this
simple example with nine observations
plotted on the space of two features
feature 1 and feature 2 now when we use
hierarchical clustering we get a
dendogram which is the treat on on the
Left that that explains how merging
should occur between observations how
observation should be clustered together
and and for example we could easily
see that this dendrogram in this
dendogram observations five and seven
are merged together and then merge that
observation a it and then merge with
observation two and then later nine and
then the other hand six and one armors
together and then they're worse with
four which were three and then at the
very end the two loops are merged
together now how are these dendrograms
formed basically we should use some
notion of distance or similarity in our
data set in order to form these
dendrograms
so going back to our plot of data points
we see that five and seven are very
similar to each other very close to each
other on this part so those are the
first two have merged to form a cluster
six and one are the next two closest
points then those are merged together
and they form a cluster the next cluster
that is formed is by joining 8 2 5 and 7
so that's that's another cluster and
then the next cluster would be adding 4
to 6 and 1 so you see that as we go up
the tree you're forming and these
vertical axes we're forming we're
merging clusters to form bigger and
bigger clusters and at the very top of
the tree always will get one cluster
that contains all the points what do we
need to make a dendrogram well we need
at least two pieces of information one
we need a similarity or distance between
observations as we discuss in the
previous example we need to know how far
the observations are from each other we
don't need to necessarily have a plot of
observations but we need to have some
notion of distance or similar to the
observation but in addition to that we
also need a measure of singularity of or
distance between clusters as I mentioned
as we go up the tree in a lot of cases
so there up being merged sets together
and in those cases we have to think
about similarities between sets or
distances between sets and this is what
is known as a linkage function so this
simple example within two clusters with
two and three observations in each
excuse me explains the notion of a
linkage function there are three
different choices that we will discuss
one is that in order to define a
distance between the two set sets we
take the minimum distance between the
observations in the two sets between the
points and the two sets and that is
known as a single linkage function the
opposite is to take the maximum distance
between between the observations in two
sets and that would give us the complete
linkage and then we also have the option
of taking the average between the
average of the distances between the
points in all in all the point points in
the two sets and that would give us the
average linkage function so of course a
few other choices of linkage function
but we will not discuss those in today's
lecture now so so we mentioned that
there are three different choices of
linkage functions which one of these
should be used the answer is that
there's no best linkage function and and
that the choice of linkage function that
is appropriate depends on
characteristics of data that are
unfortunately a lot of times unknown to
us so to give you a summary single
linkage function works best when we when
there are many outliers or the data is
not very noisy but but it's capable of
identifying clusters with the diverse
shapes on the other hand complete
linkage and average linkage to some
degree are more robust to presence of
outlier and noise in the data but they
require clusters that are roughly
comparable in size and they work better
with spherical distributions so if we
have irregular shapes and clusters that
have irregular shapes we might not be
able to distinguish them world with
complete linkage or average linkage and
here are some examples that will explain
hopefully some of these issues
so if we have outliers as is the case in
this data set where we have observations
that fall somewhere between the two main
clusters then single linkage clustering
we have difficulty separating the two
clusters from each other and instead it
might identify one point as one cluster
and all the other observations and
another as another cluster
whereas completely occasion average
linkage
a better job of separating the two
clusters from each other because they're
less prone to presence of outliers and
of course in reality we wouldn't know
which one of the two is costings is
correct where the complete linkage is
giving the right answer or average
linkage now the main difference is these
few points in this case this is
simulated data so I do know which one is
correct and and and complete linkage is
doing the correct clustering but in
general we wouldn't know the difference
between as as as I mentioned single
linkage is better at capturing clusters
that have non spherical shapes and
here's a good example of that
but single linkage especially if we
don't have if we have some separation
between clusters we distinguish clusters
that are embedded and in this case nest
is these embedded coasters within each
other whereas complete linkage and
average linkage won't be able to
separate these two clusters properly and
distinguish them from each other and and
the last example shows that the setting
when we have clusters that have very
different sizes and this case completely
is for breakdown it's the most sensitive
to having clusters of equal roughly
equal size in this case as you see it
forces the two clusters that identifies
to have roughly equal size whereas
single linkage and average linkage do a
better job of separating these two
clusters from each other now this all of
these examples that I showed you were in
the simple setting that we have two
features so we could plot the
observations of course and in the
announce of biomedical big data we often
can't talk the observations and we have
no sense of what the shape of the
clusters between clusters are and so
finding the right trace of linkage
function and in fact even finding the
right choice of distance between or
similarity between observations often
challenging now going back to the
dendrogram as we discussed at the bottom
of the dendrogram
we have a leaf for each one of the
observations and as we go up the tree
these leaves get fused to form
inches now I want to emphasize the
interpretation of the dendrogram here
and there a couple of important things
that I want to point out one is that the
earlier the points are fused together
the earlier the fusion occur the fusions
occur the more similar the observations
or the clusters are to each other so the
fusions up at the bottom of the tree
indicates that these observations are
very similar to each other whereas
fusions have happened later on indicate
that these observations are not based
about each other so that that's that's
an important piece of information that
the dendogram provides us one thing in
that that goes hand-in-hand with that is
that the vertical axis in dendogram is
very informative the height of the first
fusion between the clusters containing
two different observations corresponds
to how different they are from each
other so if you look at these two
observations for example there are views
at the very bottom of the cluster so
that that indicates that the distance
between these two observations is very
small whereas if you consider this leaf
and another leaf in this branch place
after here their corresponding clusters
are worth much higher in the graph so
two distance between those two clusters
is around seven so there is a
significant difference between points
that are version earlier in the
dendrogram than points that was much
higher than the rapid and the vertical
axis provides us that information on the
other hand the horizontal axis is not
informative at all and in the dendrogram
so we should not interpret the
horizontal axis in any informatively and
the prime example of that are these two
leaks to consider hopefully you guys see
my cursor consider this observation this
leaf and the one that is very jacent to
it this leaf and even though these are
adjacent to each other
on the horizontal axis they're in fact
that last two observations to America to
get merged at the very top of the tree
so there they can't be any more
different from each other in this
example so the observation
adesh
whose little horizontal axis and the
layout of the opti the lease on the
horizontal axis is somewhat arbitrary
you should not interpret that in an
informative way now depending on where
we cut this standard line or when we cut
this tree we get different number of
clusters so for example we could cut the
tree somewhere around here and then we
will get two clusters these red and
green clusters so anywhere from the very
top to a distance excuse me seven we get
two clusters if we cut the dendrogram
further towards the bottom we get more
and more clusters so if we cut the
dendrogram somewhere here we get three
clusters and if we cut it further down
we get additional numbers identified now
one thing to keep in mind and is
important is that as we discussed
fusions that occur earlier in the
dendrogram I indicate more similar
clustering so if we have and if we cut
the dendrogram further down we are
cutting into groups of observations are
more similar with each other so so
ideally you want to look for gaps and
where the fusions occur so in this
example cutting it at two or three is
sensible
three years probably the best choice but
cutting it to get two or three and then
do grams is sensible but cutting is to
get more clusters it's not very
reasonable because then then we're
cutting into clusters that are somewhat
homogeneous inside them now let's look
at how these dendrograms would look like
in a somewhat more realistic setting and
this is the clustering of NCI 60 data
there are 64 cancer cell lines and for
each one of them about 6,800 genes were
measured and if you use complete linkage
average
linkage and single linkage dendrograms
that we get are somewhat very different
than the Pentagon's they showed you and
that come simple an example for one the
clusterings in in all these dendrograms
are less clear that there is less
separation between the debt now between
the leaves between either clusters and
then all the leaves are somewhat
combined towards the top of the tree
with complete linkage we get a little
bit more separation towards the top but
but with average linkage and single
linkage basically we don't have good
separation between the clusters another
feature of these high dimensional
settings that we see in this example is
the behavior behavior of single linkage
clustering and this is often due to the
noise and that is induced because of the
high dimensionality and a lot of high
dimensional examples single linkage is
not capable of identifying meaningful
clusters and and what we see is that
clusters are formed by adding one
observation at a time so as you go
higher on the tree one observation is
added to the previous cluster and that
cluster gets bigger and that's that's
the dominant pattern that we see and
this is often referred to as chaining
behavior of single linkage clustering so
in a lot of high dimensional
applications single linkage despite its
appealing properties and effect clusters
with diverse shapes is not very
effective and in high dimensions well so
we we discussed briefly hierarchical
clustering it's an easy to interpret
method it gives a family of nested
clusters
it's computation rather efficient and it
also works in high dimensions but the
caveat that we just discussed the
disadvantages of our clustering is that
it doesn't really correspond to a formal
optimization criteria it doesn't achieve
anything in any any formal objective and
the final solution is chosen by the data
scientists or the analyst and that could
be somewhat arbitrary
and and as we discuss different merging
or splitting criteria it could give rise
to different solutions in contrast to
hierarchical clustering and
Rockhold methods k-means clustering
which is an example of partition based
methods tries to found find the best
partition of the observations into a
priori define the number of clusters so
the first consider sort of that want to
partition our observation to K clusters
and K is given and then k-means
clustering tries to partition the
observations in the best possible way
into these number of clusters it's a
simple and intuitive it has a simple and
intuitive objective function and it's
competition rather efficient could be
applied to datasets with a large number
of observations however the main
drawback is that there's no hierarchy
among clusters if we change K for
example from two to three that instead
of wanting to clusters now you want
three clusters there's no guarantee that
that we have a hierarchy among clusters
so the clustering memberships might
completely change to explain the k-means
clustering I briefly this would like to
discuss its algorithm partly because the
actual optimization function that is
associated that k-means clustering is is
not tractable finding the exact solution
to that is not tractable on the other
hand we could find very good approximate
solutions using a simple algorithm the
idea is that we first randomly assign
each one of the observations to one of K
clusters and then we iterate two steps
until the clustering memberships don't
change anymore first we calculate
cluster centroids this is the mean of
the observations in each one of the
clusters and then we assign reassign
cost of memberships we assign each point
to the centroid that is closest to it so
here's an illustration of that procedure
this is a data set suppose that we want
to cross right into three clusters first
we randomly split the observations into
one of three clusters red blue and green
and then we just simply calculate the
centroids the mean of the red the mean
of the blue and the mean of the green of
course in this case these means are not
that different from each other but now
I'm galettes
we could now assign each one of the
observation
essentially that is closest to it so now
we get these three clusters in the data
and in fact if we continue this this
process then then you would recalculate
the centrally and and then even after
ten iterations we don't get in any any
changes so in this think some more
toilet sample we get the partitions very
quickly just by one pass of the k-means
clustering algorithm and in many
examples this is algorithm volksfrei
converges very quickly and we get the
results of a good partition of the data
into K clusters now as we discussed
k-means clustering does not give us a
hierarchy among clusters if we change K
the memberships will change kagan's
also works best when we have compact
spherical clusters but somewhat
comparable number of members so in that
regard k-means behavior a lot of times
is somewhat similar to confusion in kiss
clustering and one of the issues that
might occur with k-means clustering is
that it may result in smaller empty
clusters and this could be potentially
do the beauty presence of outliers a
remedy for this is to remove those empty
clusters and refit the partition with
the algorithm in a lot of cases that
that improves the solution but
nonetheless this clicker now here are
some examples of settings where k-means
could work well in this case we came in
such a good job of partitioning the
observation to four sets it's just a
partition where a single linkage
clustering gets gives just one big
cluster and then observations on the
periphery that are just being
distinguished from from those and
similarly k-means clustering would be
able to separate these two clusters from
each other where a single linkage
clustering because of this sort of
somewhat overlap between the two
clusters won't be able to separate them
from each other and identifies these
artificial clusters on the other hand
k-means as we discussed prefers
spherical
distributions so it has a differ
faulty has difficulty identifying these
embedded clusters where as single
linkage does a good job of that and and
also and in this example k-means can't
distinguish between these two clusters
where a single linkage can can do a good
job and in that example now in k-means
we discussed that we need to know the
number of clusters but that's also
somewhat true about hierarchical
clustering we need to decide where to
cut the dendrogram and how many clusters
do in general this is a difficult
question like many other unsupervised
learning tasks we need the validations
that set approach and these approaches
don't work directly in unsupervised
learning techniques unlike supervised
learning where we could do
cross-validation for example in order to
choose the tuning parameter in k-means
orchestrating this is not trivial and it
is somewhat difficult there are some
guidelines for example eyes we discuss
in Harlow clustering we can examine the
dendrogram see what the gaps are in the
dendrogram and use those in order to
identify the right number of clusters
there are also some guidelines for
k-means clustering we could vary the
number of clusters we could vary K and
then look at the value of the objective
function over different case and then
the guideline is that we should be
looking at the code on code elbow and in
the clock meaning that usually the value
of G of the objective function drops
down quickly and then it flattens out
and then this part were we see that the
flattening of the curve of the objective
function usually corresponds to the
right number of clusters for the data
but again these are somewhat arbitrary
and they're not very rigorous guidelines
now the best probably the best possible
way to find the number of clusters is
again to go back to the fact that
hierarchical clustering k-means
clustering in general clustering and
unsupervised learning are parts of the
data analysis pipeline so we could in
fact consider
varying the value of K
or the number of clusters and see the
effect of it and the downstream analyses
oftentimes as we discussed we use her
unsupervised learning to further to
identify some patterns and then use
supervised learning techniques later on
in order to validate these for in order
to do some downstream analysis and the
best possible way to identify what is
the right number of clusters for that
data so that we're analyzing is to use a
validation set approach or a training
test approach in conjunction with that
supervised learning technique to at the
end determine what what is the
appropriate number of clusters that that
we should consider there are some
challenges and caveats but clustering as
we discussed there's of course no
one-size-fits-all solution for
clustering or even a good definition of
what what clustering should look like
there's not a single best criterion for
obtaining a partition because as we've
discussed the definition is by design
somewhat vague in biomedical big data
clusters henpeck could have arbitrary
shapes and sizes and we don't have a way
of identifying sort of what are the
shapes and sizes of clusters or
understanding what the shapes and sizes
of clusters so we won't be able to
distinguish these from each other and it
is very hard to evaluate how well is
clustering algorithm performs especially
when we are working with biomedical big
data so these are some of the issues
that come up when we try to evaluate and
validate clustering results and we
should keep in mind that again the best
way to do this would be just to view
clustering as part of the data analysis
pipeline and in validating that
perspective the final point that I want
to emphasize on is that the
pre-processing steps today battle
wrangling and steps including centering
and scaling for example could affect the
result of clustering so again we should
see clustering as a step in that whole
process and think about sort of the
consequences of for example whether we
send
scale the observation and the
observations or variables and the effect
that that would have on the clustering
outcomes so so now moving on from
clustering to dimension reduction as we
discussed the goal of clustering is to
identify homogeneous subgroups in data
on the other hand dimension reduction
methods try to find low dimensional
representation of data that maintain
important features of the data today we
will only talk about probably the most
widely used for dimension reduction
technique which is the principal
components analysis or PCA but there are
many other choices out there we could we
won't talk about multi-dimensional
scaling independent components analysis
so self-organizing maps and non-negative
matrix factorization and many variants
of these methods this is a growing and
an active area of research but we will
just talk about the basic concepts using
the PCA as an example now why do we use
the Metra induction there are many
reasons to do the measure introduction
for example in high dimensions data
visualization becomes very difficult we
can't really talk many two-dimensional
scatter plots if we have large number of
features P we would want to reduce the
dimensionality in order to aid
visualization for example often there's
high degree of redundancy in the data
there's correlation among features so we
don't need to have all the features in
order to understand the properties of
data or characteristics of the data the
many features in any study that may not
be informative for that particular study
you could think of these as somewhat
noise features and and it would be
helpful to somewhat reduce the effect of
these features and come up with dementia
reductions that that will correspond to
easier analyses
and dimensional reduction techniques can
retain important features of the data
while reducing these noise features and
also redundancy in our analysis both to
aid visualization and also to help with
unsupervised our infinitives as we will
discuss later so the most well known
dimensional reduction method I mentioned
in principal component analysis or PCA
the idea is that we start with the data
matrix X the same data matrix that we
had at the beginning this is an N by P
array of values for n subjects and and P
features the ideas that's not all these
features are needed you might be able to
reduce the dimension and and the goal of
PCA is to find a lower dimensional
representation of data that captures
most of the information and data and NPC
is widely used in biomedical big data
for example in population genetics and
genome-wide Association studies PP BCA
is used to correct for stratification
it's used to study heat there are
patterns of human migration and and also
it's used to identify and correct batch
effects last week and last week's
webinar it was discussed that batch
effects would have severe and
consequences on the performance of super
ordinary techniques and usually as a
pre-processing step we need to identify
these artificial effect so batch effects
or artificial non biological effects
that are results of pre possible results
of data acquisition or processing steps
and it would be important to identify
these and and try to correct for these
so that we have a data set that truly
represents biological important
biological information and one of the
main techniques that is tools and
techniques for identifying and
correcting back effects is based on PCH
so to explain the main idea of PCA again
let's look at a simple example with two
features x1 x2 and some observations in
this in this scatter plot of two
features
now the goal of PCA as we discussed is
whether we can find a lower dimensional
representation so for example whether we
could find a good one dimensional
representation of the data in this
example well we have some choices we
could use one of the two variables so we
could use either x1 or x2 as our
dimension reduction probably a better
choice is to use a linear combination of
the two so we could you form a new
variable Z 1 that is a linear
combination of x1 and x2 basically with
an average of two variables so this
would correspond to basically a new
direction depending on the choices of W
1 and W 2 we would get different lines
and then the question is how do we
choose these weights W 1 and W 2 and PCA
is answer to this question is that the
direction that is most informative is a
direction that captures the majority of
the variant data so we in PCA we look to
find the direction that that captures
the most of the variance in the data or
most of the variation in data now so in
this toy example that corresponds to the
direction of maximum correlation between
X 1 and X 2 now what if we needed
another direction so suppose that we
wanted another direction Z 2 that was
another linear combination of X 1 X 2
well to find additional principal
components and these directions are
referred to as principal components we
choose the subsequent linear
combinations that are orthogonal or
perpendicular to the previous ones so
once we found this direction again this
is called the principal component or a
PC once we found this direction we try
to find future directions that are
orthogonal to the previous one so that
what that means is that we will choose
the vector V of weights that is
orthogonal to the previous vector W but
still explains the majority of
variability in the data of course in the
two dimensional setting once we find the
vector V that is orthogonal W then we
don't have any choice
is a vector this is always the case for
the last PC the last PC is defined
directly by by by the fact that is
perpendicular to all the previous ones
however if P is larger than 2 then we
have many choices for the second PC and
then we will choose among those the one
that explains the maximum variation in
the data and it's orthogonal to the
previous ones so in this example again
this is a choice of second PC is
somewhat clear it's the one that is
orthogonal to the first one and then
basically when you look at this plot
based on the two principal components
PCA just defines a new coordinate system
for the observations that now you can
think of plotting the observations
across this new quote along this new
coordinate system instead of the
original coordinate system and that's a
lot of times how we use PCA in order to
do data visualization and high
dimensions if we had more height in
higher dimensions when we have P larger
than m2 PCA again defines a lower
dimensional representation and in fact
it defines a lower dimensional
representation that is the best
approximation to the data so we could
define this two dimensional
approximation of data where we project
each one of the observations into this
plane and that would give us the PCA
solution so the PCA a solution with
first principal component and the second
principal component captures the the
majority of variability that that could
be captured in by a two dimensional
representation this is the best
approximation to data that we can get so
so here's a classical example
application of PCA on a data set that
was collected back in 1973 and these are
statistics crime statistics in an arrest
for a hundred thousand residents for
assault murder and rape along with the
percentage of urban population of 50
United States as we can see from the
two-dimensional scatter plots
there is some correlation between some
of these crime statistics murder
installs for example are correlated with
each other there's some correlation
between assault and rape and assault and
murder and urban population is less
correlated with these two but
nonetheless there is some correlation in
the data now if we apply PCA I won't go
into detail of how we get these if you
apply PCA and then caught the
observation in the first in the space of
the first two pcs we see some
interesting patterns now just using two
principal components so instead of now
having four variables we've reduced the
dimensionality into two and that allows
us to do visualization for example and
identification of interesting patterns
so in the space of the first two pcs for
example we have the observations plotted
and and and in this particular plot
which is referred to as a by plot we
also have the variables or features
overlaid in this plot using these arrows
so this shows that basically the first
principal component is some other than
average of all four variables as we saw
these variables were correlated with
each other so the first principal
components in these settings usually
captures an overall average of two
variables so long the first principal
components as we moved to a right we
have higher levels of some combination
of urban population rape assault and
murder in the states that are on the
right and lower values of those in the
state was in the states that are in
far-left whereas the second principal
component Direction tells us something
interesting about the contrast between
assault and murder that have negative
values on the second principal component
versus urban population in degree but
have positive values of this and this
second principal component so basically
states that are at this at the bar
half of this the second principle
component are those that have higher
rates of rest due to assault and murder
and states that are in the top half of
this the second just in the top half of
the clause for based on the second
principle component but those have
higher rates of arrest based on grape
and also have alright higher urban
population and in those states so so
already this plot gives us some really
interesting information about the data
that we could not just see based on by
by looking at the plots to the scatter
plots just just plotting everything in
the space of the first two pcs in
additional dimension reduction gives us
the way of identifying these interesting
features now again the question that
comes up is that how many peas in
principal components should be used as
before this is somewhat tricky question
to answer on the one hand increasing the
number of principal components with it
by increasing the number of its fullness
we would include more and more variation
of the data and we explain more of the
variation in the data on the other hand
if we use too many pcs we don't get the
advantage and benefits of dimension
reduction and in ideally want the
smallest number of species that captures
the important information of the data
unfortunately this is not easy
maybe it's trust and again the best way
you can to achieve this although there
are some guidelines and some ideas about
how we could choose the number of pcs is
to think about PCA as part of
unsupervised learning indeed data
analysis pipeline and and try to
identify the number of clusters that is
best based on that as one example in
last week's webinar one of the methods
that was discussed was principal
component regression which is basically
applying PCA to first obtain a lower
dimensional representation of the data
and then apply either regression or
classification on that space in order to
predict the outcome or find associations
with the features and that in that space
and this is a very powerful tool
specially for prediction it's not as
great for finding Association because we
are now in the students lower
dimensional space that that is a
combination of the previous variables
but nonetheless a really good way of
identifying how many principal
components we should include is to look
at the outcome of that congressional
classification at the end and then try
to use cross validation for example in
order to identify how many principal
components should be used in order to
get the best prediction in the test data
okay to summarize I want to emphasize
again I know that I've mentioned this a
couple times that repeated this over and
over but this is really important and
unsupervised learning is just one step
in the data analysis pipeline so we
should see it as part of the data
analysis pipeline and the results of
supervised learning should ideally value
that in that pipeline we widely use
learning techniques to pre-process data
so it's using exfoliat or data analysis
to a data visualization data wrangling
for example as we discuss it's used to
correct for batch effects and it's also
used for data visualization as we saw
some examples of it it's used to extract
feature and discover patterns in the
data so all of this was part of
exploratory data analysis and we use it
to generating hypotheses but it's also
used in confirmatory data analysis as we
just discuss in the example of principal
component aggressions these unsupervised
learning techniques are used to improve
the performance of supervised learning
techniques or in conjunction with
supervisors I think three things in
confirmatory data analysis a selection
of tuning parameters and validation of
the results of post deployed learning
techniques is often difficult this is
partly because we don't have a response
we don't have an outcome to use for
example in order to do cross-validation
however if we see it again as
part of the whole pipeline we would be
able to use the outcome of the analysis
if this is not feasible if there's truly
no outcome then what we would want to do
is to try to validate what be fine and
an independent data set so let's say we
get some cost rains and we should repeat
the clustering and an independent data
to see if the questions that we get are
somewhat similar but if we use that cost
rating from the previous and study
whether those correspond to interesting
patterns change in a dataset as well
and and especially when we are using
entrepreneur name techniques purely as
exposed to the analysis tools we should
be cautious about the interpreting there
there is also those analyses we should
keep in mind that without external
validation there's danger that might not
be able to reproduce the findings of our
exposure to the data analysis and what
what we are getting is could be
potentially just features that we have
[Music]
captured by by it by looking at the data
and they might not be generalizable to
other data sets and other studies and
with that I want to thank you for
listening and I'm happy to answer any
questions that they like thank you so
much Ellie that was a really great
overview on unsupervised machine
learning I do want to encourage folks
who are in our audience if you have any
questions to use a little question
submission system send in a few
questions and I'll try and get to as
many as we can before the top of the
hour one question for you Ali is you had
made in your discussion on the creation
of the dinner grams and your clustering
algorithm discussion
you mentioned measures of distance are
there any caveats about the choice of
the measure of distance whether it's a
Euclidean metric whether it's like a
city block metric or perhaps even an
information criteria that one needs to
worry about absolutely so there are many
choices as you mentioned
some of them that measures the distance
or similarity and and the main caveat is
that there is no best measure that
different data sets and different
depending on what are the clusterings
within the data different measures might
work better in different situations and
unfortunately that's another thing that
we won't know and the best way to do
clustering is to often try different
metrics and try different similarity or
distance measures and see which one of
them validates better so again I want to
go back to this idea that I suppose
learning is part of pipeline which one
of them gives us results that are more
generalizable if we look at the test set
so ideally we should try a couple of
different choices we should try a couple
of different choices of distance or
similarity to see which one of them is
war and gives us more generalizable
results okay great well one other
question was in principal component
analysis are there any recommended axes
rotation techniques which might be
useful in helping to make your results
more interpretable well so the principal
component is by design a way of rotating
the axes so basically going back to the
slide that they had on it's basically
what principal components does is that
it gives you a new coordinate system
that basically it's a rotation of the
original data now now in addition to
rotation in higher dimension you're
getting this rotation in a reduced
dimension so instead of having a
three-dimensional space you have a
two-dimensional space but but principle
already three tries to find the optimal
rotation that that that that is and that
that captures the information in data
the the feature of the principal
component the property principle
component is that the two axes are
orthogonal to each other
so
that helps open up the correlation
basically between observations so
instead of having observations plotted
along the correlation as we have X 1 and
X 2 now if you look at this new
coordinate system in this new coordinate
system the observations can be opened up
from each other more easily so I would
say just just looking at principal
component usually gives us gives us the
right rotation of the data a lot of
times the question is how many of these
pieces should be used or which one of
the pieces should be look at when we
look at pc-1 pc2 or should we look at PC
153 if you're doing to these scatter
plots so that's usually the more
difficult question to answer
so in spew should inspect your data I
guess is inspect the result and yes I
will tell you yes what which kind of
brings me to one of the questions from
our audiences there seems to be a lot of
supervision in unsupervised machine
learning how do you kind of strike a
balance between how much input or you
know kind of trial and error that a user
might input with letting the Machine do
what it does so that's actually a really
good question and in general I would say
that I suppose
learning is one of the areas that
supervision if you will or involvement
of the data scientist is somewhat
critical many of the unsupervised
learning techniques are harder to put
into sort of an automatic framework a
lot of times there's need for data
scientists to be engaged and this is a
really good opportunity for example to
interact with and for interaction from
data scientists with the data to see
sort of what are the interesting
features we don't want to do this to the
extent that they're basically finding
artificial patterns in the data and
again that goes back to finding patterns
that are generalizable in a test dataset
or in cost validation but but
[Music]
times of supervised learning things do
require some involvement by it by the
data scientists so how does that so if
you're in the your interest is in
building a model of the data are there
different approaches that you need to be
considering between the use of a
supervised approach versus an
unsupervised learning approach well we
use unsupervised learning techniques a
lot of times to gain insight into sort
of what are the characteristics of the
data and what are the features of the
data and those will help us determine
what are the right models what are the
proper and supervised learning
techniques so that's that's one way that
these tools are used together the other
way as I briefly discuss in the case of
principle component regression is that
sometimes unsupervised learning
techniques are used in order to aid
supervised learning techniques in order
to improve the performance of supervised
learning techniques so the final model
is basically using unsupervised learning
to first reduce a dimension and then we
build a prediction model or or let's say
a regression model so so we could use
these in conjunction and use them
together in order to get a model that is
most appropriate but but the answer to
some extent depends on what is the goal
of our analysis so so if the goal is
purely prediction we could use principal
component regression and PCA together
with regression or prediction however if
the goal is to find association between
the original features and the outcome
that thing doesn't work very well
because each one of the pcs is a linear
combination of all the original features
so we can't use principal component
regression two in order to identify
which one of the out features is
associated with the outcome so the
answer to this question somewhat depends
on what is the goal of our analysis do
we want to do a good job of prediction
or do we want to find association
between the features and the outcome and
once we
that question will determine what are
the right choices of combinations of
supervised and unsupervised learning
techniques well fantastic well we've run
out of time and so we need to kind of
sign off now but I want to thank Ellie
for his talk today a really fantastic
overview of unsupervised machine
learning I want to thank those of you
who who signed in and thank you for your
questions and we'll look forward to
talking to you again next week
once again Thank You Allie enjoy your
weekend everybody thank you